THE AMNESTY FANATICS ARE
DEFEATED ONCE AGAIN.
AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE" ."
JOINING ME NOW FOR A REACTION IS
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN BOB
GOODLATTE, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
HAS COSPONSOR IN HIS OWN
IMMIGRATION BILL.
CONGRESSMAN, HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
GETTING A EIGHT, DISASTER.
BUSH-SCHUMER WENT DOWN IN
FLAMES, 1200 PAGES.
THE McCAIN-BUSH DISASTER BACK
IN 2006-2007, ANOTHER KILLER FOR
REPUBLICANS.
YOUR VIEW HERE?
>> WE HAVE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE,
WE HAVE CONTROL OF THE SENATE,
WE HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT WHY WOULD WE TURN THAT
CONTROL BACK OVER TO THE
DEMOCRATS AND HAVE ANOTHER
FIASCO LIKE THE ONES THAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED?
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE, BUT THIS ISSUE IS HOW ARE
WE GOING TO SECURE OUR BORDERS,
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES LIKE THE
ASYLUM LOOPHOLE THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED, AND THERE ARE MANY
OTHERS, AND MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
THEIR GOVERNMENT WILL KEEP THEM
SAFE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
ALONG THE BORDER OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT THE LEGISLATION THAT
I ALONG WITH MIKE McCALL,
CHAIRMAN OF THE IMMIGRATION
SUBCOMMITTEE, MARTHA McSALLY,
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OR
COMMITTEE, CAME UP WITH AND IT
DOES ADDRESS THE DACA SITUATION
IN A FAIR WAY, BUT ONLY IN
EXCHANGE FOR MAKING SURE THAT WE
DON'T LET THIS PROBLEM CONTINUE
IN THE FUTURE.
>> Laura: SO IN THIS DISCHARGE
PETITION MADNESS -- PEOPLE HAVE
IS, THEIR EYES ARE GLAZING OVER
I'M SURE, BUT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WEIRD STUFF
CAN HAPPEN WITH A DISCHARGE
PETITION, AS YOU KNOW.
WOULDN'T ANN CATCH AND RELEASE.
THEY WOULDN'T END THE CHAIN
MIGRATION.
ALL THESE THINGS THAT ARE
MULTIPLIER EFFECTS ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND IMMIGRATION
AMNESTY IN THIS COUNTRY.
MASSIVE INCREASES IN LEGAL
IMMIGRATION, NONE OF IT WOULD BE
AFFECTED.
>> THE RISK IS YOU WILL GET AN
UNBALANCED BILL WHERE YOU WORK
ADDRESS DACA AND NONE OF THESE
OTHER THINGS AND 180, 190
DEMOCRATS WERE JOINED WITH 30 OR
40 REPUBLICANS AND PASS
SOMETHING THAT THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
AND THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
CERTAINLY THE REPUBLICAN BASE
WOULD NOT BE SATISFIED WITH
BECAUSE IT WOULDN'T ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM.
>> Laura: BUT CONGRESSMAN
CABELLO SAID A DISCHARGE
PETITION IS PRECISELY THE WAY TO
GET THIS DONE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> NO ONE HERE IS INTERESTED IN
A SPECTACLE.
WE ARE INTERESTED IN HAVING A
DEBATE.
WE ARE ACTUALLY INTERESTED IN
ANSWERING THE PRESIDENT'S CALL
TO ACTION IN SEPTEMBER OF LAST
YEAR WHEN HE CHALLENGED CONGRESS
TO COME UP WITH A BIPARTISAN
SOLUTION TO THIS IMMIGRATION
QUESTION.
THIS DISCHARGE PETITION PROCESS
IS PROBABLY THE MOST
CONSTRUCTIVE EVER BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT BRINGING FORWARD ONE BILL.
WE ARE OFFERING THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR FOUR BILLS TO COME TO THE
FLOOR, INCLUDING ONE THAT'S
BACKED BY IMMIGRATION HARDLINERS
AND ANOTHER THAT WOULD BE
DRAFTED AND FILED BY THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE.
>> THE ANSWER IS HE SHOULD WORK
WITH THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
AND WITH THE COMMITTEE, THE